bonjour à vous merci d'être avec nous en
direct sur arte france justement pour
discuter de cette rencontre du président
qu'elle est quel est l'objectif
concrètement de cette visite d' emmanuel
macron en lituanie et en lettonie
alors écoutez je pense que la france 2
des manuels macro et seat a de temps en
temps d'apparaître sur la tène
internationale surtout en période où
l'otan et les états unis sont dans une
situation disons 2 d'imprécisions vu les
tensions kia cee
mais là on voit que le président
maquereau a pris nettement le le parti
d'as d'un camp contre un autre puisque
il a appelé le président biélorusse hien
a démissionné en même temps il va dans
les deux pays les plus engagés avec la
pologne contre l'actuel gouvernement
telle russie et là on peut on peut
supposer évidemment qu'il rencontrera
l'ats la porte parole s'il veut dire de
l'opposition pylori siècle et à vilnius
donc en fait ils contribuent à prendre
parti ce qui l'empêchera de jouer le
rôle de médiateur qu'il tente de jouer à
sur d'autres terrains internationaux
donc c'est un peu étonnant c'est dans
une certaine mesure puisqu'il limite sa
marge de manoeuvre avant même de centre
d'entrer dans le vif du sujet peut-être
croit-il que le président biélorusse
hien est affaibli ce qui veux me semble
tout à fait une erreur aujourd'hui le
président guy naury si elle occasionne
qu un rôle pris l'initiative sur le
terrain intérieur comme sur le terrain
international
donc on va voir mais là je pense qu'il
ay le prison macron a perdu une des
cartes qu'il aurait pu jouer alors
justement la lituanie est la lettonie
désapprouve l'élection de loukachenko si
la france ces deux pays s'accordent est
ce que ça peut avoir une influence
contre alexandre loukachenko est ce que
ça peut peser dans la balance finalement
ça ne fera que contribuer à repousser
encore plus javier le russie n'ont pas
seulement dans le camp de
en russie il faut savoir que le
président de la commission des affaires
étrangères du parlement biélorusse hien
a annoncé qu'après tout la biélorussie
avait l'appui de la chine avait des
relations étroites avec l'iran et le
vietnam
allez développer ses relations avec
l'inde
il faut jamais oublier que la ruelle que
la biélorussie est membre et 17
seulement européen du mouvement des
états non alignés qui est quand même un
des grands ensembles rassemblant chacune
des organisations internationales
rassemblant le plus grand nombre d'états
sur la planète donc justement là où
c'est le cas c'est le cas dans cette
direction n'est peut-être pas le
meilleur moyen de sortir comme vous
disiez de l'impasse dans laquelle on se
trouve justement comment est-ce que la
russie perçoit ce déplacement
présidentiel
bon c'est payé là puisque dans le jdd
emmanuel macron avait déclaré que la
russie ne jouait pas son rôle de
médiateur
si par médiateur on entend qu'elle doit
pousser l ou un autre le président
actuel de 10 lots russie a sorti à
démissionner évidemment il ne joue pas
ce rôle mais ils font romeu il faut
analyser les rapports de force
réellement existant sur le terrain
peut-être que le casino n'a pas eu les
80 % de voix qui prive de ravoir mais il
est quand même clair d'après tous les
sondages ce que l'on a et les enquêtes
d'opinion sociologique en biélorussie
qui a quand même une majorité de
biélorussie 1 qui le soutiennent et que
l'opposition ne représente qu'un tiers
ou un peu plus d'un tiers de la
population ce qui est beaucoup mais ce
qui est insuffisant pour pouvoir prendre
le pouvoir dans la question bruno
drobinsky pourquoi ne pas se rendre
également en estonie quels sont les très
rapidement quelles sont les relations et
ce collègue toni n'est finalement pas du
côté des manuels macron bel esprit est
plutôt proche de l'allemagne pour toutes
sortes de raisons ou carrément des pays
scandinaves c'était cas ce qu'on appelle
l'europe du nord c'est-à-dire finlande
suède au sein de l'union européenne donc
c'est peut-être une des raisons
l'autre c'était tout simplement
justement que je pense que nos prisons
macumba dans les pays si je peux dire de
la vie
de front entre guillemets face à la
biélorussie et que l'estonie est assez
éloignée boutons plus éloignés tout au
moins de la question des mauriciennes
que ne le sont les deux pays voisins de
la biélorussie c'est à dire la lettonie
et la lituanie on remarquera d'ailleurs
que le président macro ne va pas non
plus en pologne sans doute y a des
différends entre les deux pays sans
doute sur d'autres dossiers mais que la
pologne aussi jouent un rôle très
important en biélorussie mais elle est
plutôt proche de la grande bretagne
bruno dreams qui merci pour toutes ces
précisions je rappelle que vous êtes
historien et maître de conférences à
l'inalco merci à vous